now so a before we start and a half a
cup of announcement and the presentation
will be available to download both in
English and Spanish as a PDF after the
session in espanol presentazione a
thoroughly phony bleep para descargar
time to neglect come on a panel in for
my birthday Fe para todos so if you have
any questions through the presentation
please submit any questions via the chat
box as they come to mind an outlet
respond at the end of the presentation
so let's get this on the way and taking
you for attending so the objectives of
this morning will be as follows we're
going to have a talk a little bit about
a history also very briefly we're going
to talk about some of the key components
and make research really work and we're
going to talk a little bit about
variables and in particular as it
pertains to surgery and we're going to
talk about the big problems related to
an Olivier to pain so very brief history
if the earliest manuscripts related to
animal testing date back to four
thousand Aristotle was one of the first
to conduct life animal experimentation
but I want you to pay attention to this
individual this individual by the name
Edmond Amir who said that the Prince to
the miserable torture of vivisection
places a body another natural state so
Tamara steady sustained that an animal
physiology may be affected by pain to
livi section resulting in it on reliable
data it is interesting that this man
said this back in 1655 and today this is
proven more true than ever so I know
that the word baby section can be
offensive to some but let's try to be
fine a little bit according to merriam
where
stir a heavy section is a cutting of or
operational on a living animal usually
for physiological or pathological
investigation and also an offensive term
but broadly said is really animal tech
is to relate to animals fermentation
especially if it is considered to cause
some distress to a subject so keep that
in mind and we're going to be talking
about stress the stress and pain
throughout this presentation I'd like to
preempt this by saying i'm not i'm not
going to go into any particular
techniques i know there's a lot of
there's going to be some presentations
maybe we'll will provide some of their
information but this presentation is
more philosophical and hope that it will
stimulate your mind to new thoughts okay
so let's talk about the article i could
for those of you who who work in
institutions where I don't know what the
I cook means is also the Oversight
Committee the IO represents the
institutional facial according to many
institutions in the United States but it
represents those individuals who really
know the purse strings and that can
finance the institution help that have
been given charge of responsibility for
the institutional Animal Care and Use
program so these are the administrators
and the ad is the attending veterinarian
so I cooks the Oversight Committee so
the combination of these three bodies is
really it's so important because these
are the individuals that will filter
down that will bring put together all
the standards guidelines and regulations
and for for good Animal Care and Use so
these three some individuals are really
formed a bridge for good Animal Care and
Use program so let's talk first about
the Oversight Committee what is a
toothless what is a week Iacocca or side
committee well it is defined
as an oversight committee that is a
mercy of the investigators with little
backing from the institutional facial or
your ministers and with an attending
veterinarian that has very little
influence in other words a week
veterinarian so it is a committee
betters reduce your feeble working group
in reality it is a committee with little
or no influence and investigators it is
a committee that is really at the mercy
of investigators the investigators a
principal investigators are our control
the program I have been think many of us
have been in programs with investigators
are in control and what that happens and
these are the ones were the you can
speak to them all you want it will go
one year than the other but these are
programs that are in trouble for science
will not occur like you should let's
also keep in mind not only is a weak
oversight committee we put an end week
I'll a problem but the overbearing
oversight committee also can have
similar effects because the overbearing
committee is so so so concerned like
nothing but what regulation that it will
have a similar effect that the Week
committee hands it will inhibit science
progress and science will not be correct
will not be the right signs in a program
where the Oversight Committee is an
overbearing one so what is the answer
the answer is really is a balance
between really being a tough I oversight
committee and really being one that
really works in investigators luckily in
my institution we have a great great
Oversight Committee where the balance i
believe is really there where is the
balance for each institution having but
i think i'm an institution we have
reached sort of a balance where science
is progressing at a fast pace yet
investigators are not in the
in from the from the regulations and
from from everything else so let's talk
about medical research what is what is
research will i buy medical research if
you're an investigator what your concern
is about elimination of variables really
we need to get rid of variables because
by doing that you PA you as an
investigator can focus on the study
objective that is study objective
objective can be either behavior a
treatment molecule leash and it could be
a drug it could be a particular a
surgical procedure on some type so when
one can focus on this study objective
another variables then the data can be
valid and it can be reproducible by
eliminating the variables and then that
results in trusted publication which is
really the goal so this is way too
common the investigator is looking at
his objective what he's looking for that
the treatment that drugged a compound
that that lesion that behavior but so
many variables can come into the data to
produce such mixed data that are the
only day when the data is extracted
really the investigator doesn't know
whether they're the results and the data
is as a result of really objective that
he will he or she was looking for or
from the vehicles or a combination of
both so the ideal scenario is really to
eliminate all variables so one can focus
on the objective this realistic probably
not but more realistic is that if we can
minimize these variables but manipulated
the environment the diet's able but
really working with the animals were
killed
names for the I cook with oversight
committee by having the right is
scenarios environment and practices then
the objective can be obtained with
minimal variables so that's why when the
results are published well the
investigator will say we have
ninety-five percent confidence well it
it is when when these variables are
minimized that ninety-five percent
confidence can place a role but what is
unacceptable is that that makes them
where there are all kinds of variables
because that is insulted or control
signs that is a result of our oversight
committee that is or an investigator or
the veterinarian that is weak it is a
result of investigators are on their own
and there is just not that that the
unity and that working together between
the investigators and the institution
particularly oversight committee on the
veterinarian so at the end of the day as
an investigator you won't trust the data
data that is reproducible so let's talk
about a few of the variables and
variables can be wide temperature
fluctuations come from temperature
fluctuations that's why in our facility
we have a tight controls and
temperatures and humidity painting
strands or surgical technique little to
no surgical training investigators that
are doing these procedures with very
poor training and what they're doing
they are really costing a lot of tissue
damage and we're going to that a little
bit later at the use of poor a sterile
technique inconsistent practices
pathogens and environments etc so we'll
focus in this presentation more on on
their own surgical trauma so let's talk
about surgical surgery let's talk about
trauma
so trauma trauma will lead to elevations
and catecholamines pourcel glucose and
some of the cytokines and so trauma will
impair GI motility and lower their
ability of the animal to defend itself
really the immune system and trauma will
lead to increases in oxygen demand
pulmonary workload and Rena work
workload so they do they'd agree that
trauma and in particular surgery occurs
it is to the degree that some of these
parameters are affected so they're there
by therefore the importance of
minimizing trauma so we can minimize
these variables that we can see here so
let's see some of these variables and
these or surgery variables will need to
increase it catecholamines
corticosteroids growth hormones data we
can go on and on and on it will need to
decreased and in hormonal levels Romeo
thermic responses search we will lead to
fluctuations in certain hormones like
insulin and glucagon and so it is
important that we understand that that
time is trauma so the longer an animal
is exposed the longer during surgery the
greater the trauma does why there's the
Bell so are the focus and in good
surgical training and practice so what
this graph is uh this image here tells
you is a floor in the exposure time
during surgery is increased from a half
hour to five hours infection rate will
go from three and a half to about 16 and
a half percent so the concept of time is
trauma is is key that's why we need to
go in we need to get out we didn't just
fiddle around but the importance of
minimizing time at a time so for each
minute if you do the math for each
minute of exposure we have an increase
of an infection rate of 0.05 percent
again time is stronger because a time
increased time will increase the degree
of fluid loss through the opening will
lead to tissue drawing to hypothermia
and correct at schooner depression until
the greater degree that these things
happen and the great degree that what
the variables are being introduced into
the research in time is trauma so let's
talk about the implication something for
a little bit so pain a pain is a form of
stress and stress and pain late to hear
rumors so let's define stress so
physiological stress obsess the bodies
in homeostasis the body responds was
stimulating what it is and still stress
through pain the body responds to
stimulating the nervous in the plane and
immune systems leading to short and
long-term physical effects on the body
so how how many studies are dependent on
the nervous system endocrine system the
immune system so when the cart the
greater the degree of strength the more
the fact little bit we're going to have
fun on these systems so for the sake of
definition what its homeostasis
homeostasis is a property of a system in
which variables are regulated so the
internal conditions remain stable and
relatively constant so the goal here is
to
to work in animals with the minimization
of variables and the ideal animal is one
that is in a in a good state of
homeostasis or variables and minimize
I'm the animals actually a stablehand so
again pain is a variable and you know
I'm the attending panorama institution
I'll review all protocols before they go
to the Oversight Committee and
frequently do I see and I'm sure that a
lot of you have seen the protocols where
the investigators will say I although
this is a painful procedure I am unable
to use analgesics and they gave you this
scientific excuse and they give you a
huge list of of why they can't give
analgesics they might even cite from the
literature and they will give these
great citations from the literature but
they might even tell you that a
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
will interfere this pathway in their
pathway and there is Moloch and the
other molecule as well as our opioids
now I'm going to ask you and I think
it's time that we challenge our
investigators which is worse the effect
analgesics may have them data or the
effect that pain happen there so let's
examine this because I want you to go
back to investigators I really challenge
this whole issue of the scientific
excuse for not easing in some pain
control
so what are the consequences of pain
well pain will activate a sympathetic
nervous system will have an effect on
cardiac approaches so loud noise is
essential for good living at your new
stasis vascular resistance would affect
really the heart in general oxygen
demand and and my will release
myocardial toxins and even a spleen
skinny I don't want to read all these I
just want you to know that these are
here and these are some of the arguments
that I bring to my investigators when
this here can I use pink control and it
will affect the kidneys or affect a
through the adrenal glands by affecting
the aldosterone the sodium water
retention and people corticosteroids
many many of our studies are highly
dependent in the new system and these
little corticosteroids that are that are
released they have an effect on an
immune system and of course it will for
cancer surgery there are programs it has
a higher rate of metastasis and leads to
a regulation and anorexia of the animal
the animals will lose weight and
immediately post op animals enter into
what's called catabolic state not words
the body's being itself and the goal is
to really turn these animals around as
soon as possible with paint accelerates
this thing and of course it affects
chlorine and effects a mental state
activities and also the secretion of
endogenous opioids of course leads to
high priority mian hypercapnia so let's
go back to America I think o'meara back
in 1655 had an incredible point an
animal physiology may be affected by
pain during the resection resulting in
unreliable data from any tail was
interesting at least initially about
this is that look at the gain of the day
1650
fine what ameri said back in 65 that
carried so much wisdom he really
basically had very little here to
support his statement but today we have
a lot of data to support his statement
so let's talk about minimizing surgical
trauma because obviously illegal as
minimizing variables so he can focus on
the objective so surgery skills I
practiced develop and be fined maybe I
shoulda said it should we've learned
first pretty excuse me but once they are
we find you practice and you practice
and you practice and you practice until
you're sick I have done thousands of
surgical procedure in my lifetime yeah
it's amazing even the simplest things
such as suture in a body wall I still
learn the trick and still gonna get
better there's a little thing that I'm
learning better and better and better
but don't you dare born into surgery and
can you work on with a really having
good practice for your surgical
procedure and having practice develop
and we find in the practice and
practiced and practiced let me tell you
about the miracles of acclimation let me
just many of us have ordered animals
from Charles liver from Heartland from
you know your your provider and Europe
wherever you're at and what you think
about this okay see you place the order
a the order goes to your vendor and then
the vendor goes into the animal room and
picks a few mice and these mines are
placed in in a dark box then also an o
mine when I'm the mouse and thinking
what is this this is different but this
is feel a little bit stressed and then
the the occasion of the box is closed
they start and then the animals are
taking
into the hallway and then you go on the
hallway and then people are saying how's
the weather today how are you doing to
hear these strange voices and then they
go out until the loading dock the
individual here in the box and then also
there's a new sounds new voices there's
a smell of diesel there's a smell of
strange odors that have pure the
mountain you've never smelled before if
I'm the mouse and never been this is
stressful hey I hear the sound of the
trunk and vibration on the trunk and
placed into the truck all signing the
truck takes off and next day I write the
new place new voices new hallway and
move new environment and I'm placed into
a new cage which I've never seen maybe I
was used to asking chips out of my bed
is Dharma important call what is this
life stinks if you are the mouse at
least for a few days so if you start
using than animal the day the day after
that Adam arrives you're having a
problem because you have an animal whose
homeostasis is way unbalanced so there
is data papers that are have been
published that gives you automation time
for various species at my institution we
don't a lot of investigators to torture
animals for at least for at least a
three days after they arrived so please
consider reclamation and there's
emphasis strong emphasis in the new
guide for the care and use of animals on
the issue of acclimation it could be a
strong and powerful there early so
antibiotic use you have all dealt with
investigators that everything they do
let's give on an antibiotic okay is that
a good practice first of all it should
not be used as a substitute for proper a
sepsis it is so common I've seen it I
mean I've been in business with many
now a senior commonly investigator of
everything he does you see use
antibiotics it's really an excuse to not
follow a proper aseptic technique it
needs to be used judiciously because
there's an ethical issue here if we
allow investigators that we use a
biotics indiscriminately we will be a
really resistant strains and that is an
issue that is really a false on
asymmetrical issue that will we need to
global consider another article tation
and to minimize the resistant strains at
our previous institution where a man was
there we used to go case cefazolin where
and reflections in each quarter just to
minimize the whole issue of the system
strains it's generally not recommended
and should be justified in the protocols
because it should not be a substitute
for proper aseptic technique and in fact
I don't think I know I mentioned in just
a second that it could really lead to
variables is one more thing you're
adding to your study it is best when it
is preemptively so if you know that we
need to use antibiotics it is justified
well it is best to have the highest
possible tissue levels and have the
antibiotic initial levels possible and
then a once the offense occurs the
contamination occurs and then you use
antibiotics testuser preemptively and
once pre-op is usually all you need
course there are exceptions to all these
rules and again remember there could be
a source of variables so let's assess
any Wayne antibiotics may be needed one
you have an immune deficient animal dumb
I believe these leaders antibiotics if
you're going to be entering a hollow
organs let's say the genitourinary tract
a castle intestinal tract
the thoracic cavity you in some cases
you may need and i'll be on exhibit can
you know surface justification if you're
going to have to do extensive tissue the
session and blood loss is you're
predicting or you know that at the end
of procedure you have a lot of tissue
collection blood loss maybe antibiotics
may be needed because they'd rather the
patient is actually greater the trauma
and your greater chances of infection if
there's for example in a Burton a
contamination during surgery well
definitely America's maybe needed a post
on and if you use devices Obama tears
like catheters and things like that well
your chances of infection because of the
materials that you're using could
increase a thousandfold so maybe pre-op
antibiotics may be necessary and this in
some cases even post on antibiotics if
the procedure is predicted to be a
lengthy procedure maybe you need to have
some coverage with antibiotics a.h and
ill animals and don't forget the
inexperienced searching the an
experienced surgeon is going to cost
more drama although the xperia searching
but it has had a history of infection
you know these individuals that may need
some antibiotic but as experience and
technique it gets more sophisticated and
experience increases then in for
embryonic definitely decreases so let's
talk about anesthetics and hypothermia
all anesthetics depressed or no
regulation and decrease metabolic rate
let me tell you folks fear hypothermia
fear hypothermic the effects that
hypothermia hands on the body system it
could be devastating to the animal until
your surgeon works to your data so keep
in mind that launch lose heat very
rapidly compared to larger species
because they have a high surface area
for body ratio migration this cycle
starts writing merely upon induction of
anesthesia
it can be exacerbated because of the
broadcasters who use means gas
anesthesia the regime the animal have to
share the animal we need some corporate
solutions and the better dines that
collected things and all that and many
will administer a parenteral fluids
without warming their mom and I tell you
it may be the difference between life
and death we live among reliable data
and realistic sense imperial overall
really again feared hypothermia because
it will prolong recovery and it will
increase the potency of the gas
anesthetics it will lead to
hyperventilation it will affect platelet
function and affect the heart and it
increases the viscosity of blood a chest
the best way I can illustrate this is
with a picture you have here and you're
still in this light if you have if your
point oil through a strainer you know
that or let's say if you're pouring
water through a strainer you know the
water is going to go right through it no
problem but instead of water you're
going oil oil will just stick the one it
will go through but it will go with
difficulty and they will stick to to to
the metal and but it will it it just
doesn't go like water so water the
illustration of water through a strainer
is equivalent to the gas exchange that
occurs at the OVO live on a normal form
academy but a hypothermic animal is like
it's the illustration of oil through a
strainer is sticky is like it just the
exchange doesn't occur like you should
fear hypothermia because it increases a
response stress response to surgery
and of course it needs to increase
chances of infection the wound healing
is def infected at least 22 central
nervous system depression and fears with
drug metabolism there you go so
prevention how do we prevent it well we
should all be monitoring the temperature
net animals when they're undergoing
surgery or anesthetic episode don't
forget about cutaneous warming be
careful with heating black with heating
lamps they can be dangerous you can kill
an animal with the Lambs if you not
don't have a thermometer next so if
you're monitoring that but eating
blankets worked well make sure you're
not overheating your animals and
everywhere heating is not a bad thing to
do why not submerge your you're honest
your hoses that go from your vaporizer
to the mask and it just immersing on one
water maybe you can heat up the fluids
that way one fluids don't forget to warm
them up don't you or cold fluids they
need fluids and pre-heat your prep
solutions why not put your better than
and your plexi being in the microwave
before user than the animals and of
course none of us are going to be
putting our animals in our cold
stainless steel table and don't forget
the heat pad air under the annum under
the cage under the induction and the
recovery cage remember that the
hypothermia that starts right an
induction of the animals so have a
heating pad right under the induction
chamber as well as a recovery cabbage
another point is great of great great
importance is the issue of
non-pharmacological and members of pain
control don't forget that a is not all
about the drugs it's not all about
giving the mouse or a rat and analgesic
and forget about it they are methods and
this
greater and greater emphasis in the
biomedical research community about
using non-pharmacological methods to
control pain and stress of course so
let's talk about a couple of those don't
forget about the extra calories so as we
discussed earlier when an animal
undergoes a surgical procedure that
animal is interesti-- catabolic state
which needs to be reversed as soon as
possible because we want because an
animal the catabolic state is obviously
an animal rule is not whose homeostasis
is way out of balance so why not do
something to encourage those extra
calories immediately a post-op so why
not place food on the floor that many
ways of doing this but I'll give you a
couple examples that have worked for for
us here and the institution and also I'm
the attending patterning of another set
agenda and I'll get into that in just a
second so the digest it just one of the
most recent studies that we've done is a
wee where we had a study work we did
both transplants into the tibia as you
all know a bone surgery can be quite
painful of course we cover the animals
very well with good energy analgesic
protocols pre-op and even post up but we
used gas anesthesia isoflurane these
animals were a near aleppo stopped after
closure and we place them in the
recovery cage first with the heating
blanket on the eighth and all that so
we'd like to practice what we preach so
we had a die gels you see here on the
left side this recovery die gels and I
tell you these things are so delicious
please do the wrap the the raccoon
eating dinner but all the these rats are
we starting time after time at a time
that these rats all of the deal was lift
their heads
and they were just but literally as it
were just laughing this died jail they
just loved it so think about you know
here's a good example that could be
useful and the nice thing about their
they died jealousy they're contained in
their own containers so there's no
contamination of the defeat so the other
one is bacon sausages I'm a strong
believer in the bacon softest from bio
search great company bio serve them and
these bacon soft as you see here on the
ride and we use an episode company that
are a local company that I'm the
attending veterinarian all they do on
this company is cancer research that's
it so when you are doing when cancer
research is done what's going on well
and these animals can still come to the
cancer or they can still come to the
chemotherapy so these animals can come
cachectic lose weight it can become very
malnourished very quickly these animals
can go off feed very quickly and they
look very very skinny and in fact we
have endpoints that we follow but I but
the we these animals are we need to
reach the end points and the others
going to be euthanized well we when we
started at practice on these animals are
starting to look detective before they
reach the end points you gave my bacon
softest is amazing the turn around all
these animals it's amazing how well oh
well they've done but because whereas
they may not eat the regular diet or
maybe they're eating it and they they
just not get enough calories but i think
the aroma and the taste of bacon must be
delicious for his enemies so then we'll
go to after their the bacon soft is not
only that are they eating moon or the
eating is something with higher calories
social housing
this single housing postdoc appears to
be the norm in most protocols however
study by van Lew published by van Lew at
all I showed that raster has final cord
injury had a twenty percent less chance
of survival when housed individually and
the minds that had telemetric implant
surgery when they were how socially they
recovered a lot quicker so I want to
challenge this whole concept that if i
put my minds together on my rats
together going to be picking each other
to you I think we better than that
oversight committees an article we have
been too soft in this I think because
animals are socially mice and rats are
social animals are other species as well
I think we need to reconsider this whole
issue by individual house in post-op in
Richmond let's not forget in Richmond
because what in Richmond is about is
about creating an environment that is
more like species-specific let me just
give you one scenario one example and I
used to be the Pentagon and the director
not previous institution so I had
investigated the in Concord telemetric
telemetry telemetry device in the
abdominal aorta and one day and then he
would measure blood pressure remotely
with non-invasive here to surgery these
were zucca wrath there were obese
diabetic rats so I noticed there was you
know new at this institution there was
no and no enrichment of any time so I
got investigator asked me investigator
would you mind if we take some embarked
lie but you see here in darker so you
see in the middle picture here and I so
it said church or must be that so we
packed the hill we could invite why
months later a run in to investigate
because this was not a my my head Boar's
on another side in el paso texas and i
runned investigator against test Justin
Marcel I have to tell you this ever
since we started in bar
fly yeah the new club pressure has
dropped 10 to 20 points so of course we
Laura a poster on base because we found
this to be fascinating so it tells you
that animals really need it when you
provide an environment very
species-specific the stress level goes
down while distress due to blood
pressure blood pressure goes up when the
arms of stress decreases stress and the
animals are you bring an animal closer
to homeostasis take these red boxes you
see on the right we implemented a couple
years ago we implemented the red boxes
and all breeding animals so a force you
know investigators object at first but
they all came on board and few months
later I get an email from an
investigator tells me hate myself you
will not believe it ever since we
implemented the red boxes remember the
red boxes and mice and rats don't see
through red spectrum and the thing
they're hiding from you so they're not
stressed because even they don't see the
people in the room and they tell me mr.
better details investigator tells me
myself every since we implemented red
boxes then my that my tracks I went from
an average of six pups or the letter to
twelve bucks for living I think this is
significant so don't forget the
enrichment which is a very important
part for stop recording so I'm
conclusion like these are some of it
take-home thoughts a strong but
reasonable oversight committee or
oversight overall improves science but
again as a strong and visually strong
enough it's not strong alone it's not
enough yeah but has to be a strong the
reasonable Oversight Committee don't
forget about variables because we need
to minimize surgical and non-surgical
variables for poor outcomes
don't forget about good pain control
don't forget about the complete
perioperative care and with that i mean
the farmers pharmacological
non-pharmacological the fluids the
warming of the animals they hypo they
normal thermium and don't forget that
good training means to do a surgical
technique and don't forget the cameras
and as the enrichment a good strong
enrichment program will yield better
results thank you very much and I will
entertain any questions at this point so
here's a question if we are considering
an analysis performed three three fourth
of the week after the surgical procedure
does the animal recover fully with that
without nature you see I don't see the
rest of the question okay I see you see
a here if we're considering an analysis
performing three quarters to look 34
weeks of the weeks after the surgical
procedure does the animal recovered
fully with a major intervention
antibiotics thermic regulation or
implementing these tips only works for
more acute settings no I think they work
for just about anything and you're gonna
have to tailor these to your particular
program and work with the investigators
yeah these are tips for everyone for
everything do you think that to avoid
rats to buy cage mate d do you think
that to avoid plans to buy cage mate
implants habituating that the ranch is
some kind of non-invasive implant in the
cage will help of course it will it will
I didn't talk about a explanation of the
animals to really rip up the cage and
then anything that is in the cage
centration well thank you for saying
that help you say that you listen the
effects of paint on the data and the
animal what are the effects of
analgesics on the data and the animals
have involved this list will be helpful
when explaining to scientists why the
use of analgesics is more ideal than not
for their studies so I have a list of
papers and I'll be glad to provide it to
buy a conference line of several
publications that will give you some
understanding on the effects that I know
Jesus can happen certain Catholics it is
true there analgesics and anesthetics
can affect certain pathways and in the
body but a the location is to be weighed
the effects that the energy six may have
versus the pain they have from the body
so I will be glad to provide those and
I'll work with with dr. Stefan but on
and by conference life to provide an
information hello Marcel I am are yellow
from Chile hey how are you my a nice to
have you it's their investigation papers
to show investigators the effect of
thing over their data and thanks yeah
there is some and now I can work with
dr. Braun to provide some of that
information do you account for practice
animals yes it is a I'm not sure exactly
what the question is but it's important
to have in your protocols at a few
practice animals so you can develop
technique member practice practice
practice in the case of implantation of
devices that will remain indefinitely in
the mice for how long do you recommend
to keep antibiotics after surgery well
on a previous institution where we used
to put vascular access ports we kept the
animals on antibiotics and pretty much
throughout and it's going to depend on
the implant and some implants that may
not need particular you know those are
involved more stainless steel versus
catheters may not need as much
antibiotics is going to depend
on the on the implant is thinking I'm
ground for the nice job come and
appreciate that nice to have you and how
we can meet how we can use the red boxes
like enrichment strategy and avoid
behavioral differences with control
subjects well that's an issue you're
gonna have to deal well to work through
with investigators and these red boxes
work great and you may have to really
make that decision on your oversight
committee level or working with you I
cook I cannot give you a specific answer
for every protocol apologize and okay
this person is in Spanish and I'm going
to translate it a high my Maria how are
you is is it justifiable to use
antibiotics when animals are going to be
sacrificed but three days post-op well
it depends again and maybe maybe not but
you know that an infection can sit out
very very quickly I post are people
within hours so if there is a concern
that infraction for you with your
research you may consider antibiotics
you just like said female minds recover
more quickly after telemetric surgery is
there anything to indicate nails and
arounds do the same well they're not too
many papers about but you know in
support of this statement but I would
only assume that that's the case it went
food on the cage floor help increase
calories for pain management yes it
could because when an animal is
recovered closed off he may the pain is
health may preclude the animal from at
least immediately post up from just
reaching after the feed hopper so puddin
with fluid on the bottom of the cage it
could be helpful I'm more partial to
some of these like recovery gels and the
bacon softies but yeah you can use those
do you think analgesia is possible and
pregnant it's possible pregnant and also
affecting the tops oh yeah definitely
there are many you need to read the
inserts and you know look at the
literature but yes I think it could be
used and it should be used and we are a
real partial towards envelopes handsome
and personally thank you for your
presentation water what else do you
recommend to provide two mice and rats
for extra calories if we can access the
dodgy else and the bacon I I I have in
the past very effectively a provided was
called a peanut butter Chow mix it what
I deal is that I mix I haven't have
powdered a Chow rodent chow with a half
peanut butter and it makes it a little
bit with water they're going to make
make it a little bit more palatable and
I put it in a little container and the
bottom of the cage and I think I have
reached the end of my time ten o clock
done hey can I continue or should I stop
at this point i will send down a chair
and to see if i should stop until he
tells me ok tell me how to continue for
a few more mins for rats in a tail
suspended study i am using extra
calories an enrichment but not red boxes
what else could i provide to alleviate
stress and you may improve our there I
mean they I what I advise you to do is
because there are so many suggestions go
to a bio sir biol hyphen surf.com they
have all kinds of enrichment devices
that you can just choose from and that
will give you more comprehensive answer
that i will give you in just five
seconds some Mexicans recommend
analgesic treatment for two days post-op
well let's do three days post-op why do
you recommend for your investigators
don't have you noticed any difference
between duration of treatment we
we work very closely with veterinary by
science institute and who has also
worked very closely with paul flag now
many of you know Paul flag now read
individual great thought in the field
and and together with him we have
developed some tables that will help
decide on them the type of analgesia
they are for the particular technique
and for the duration we generally for my
eye for moderate-to-severe surgical
procedures we recommend at least two or
more like three days so it really gonna
depend you can have to make a clinical
assessment but we will be glad to
provide a link to do these tables okay
thank you for the compliments for
researchers who are adamant the energy
seas will alter their data how hard to
push them to use them for example other
institutions several other researchers
declare opioids will greatly affect
their studies andressa getting the
effects of inflammation and the immune
system I had the exact same problem so I
pushing and they win many times remember
I don't know who made a what you roll
adam is at your institution but if
you're the attending veterinarian don't
take this responsibility on your own
include your your I you I cook your
oversight committee in making a decision
at least you are presenting the data
told committee and by water than
majority that decision is made I do
pushing to some extent but there's a
point where I just can't go anymore I
need to let the the article that always
a committee make a decision good
question in terms of larger animals we
usually give IV dextrose but it becomes
difficult for mice and rodents and it's
a chance to maintain glucose gallery we
recommend for mice and rats to before
every unaesthetic episode because
anesthesia will need to hypertension
only to get all the promise that we we
discussed earlier a I we recommend for
mice in general at least i have 2 1 ml
of preoperative fluids should be given a
bit of an animal is cachectic of an
animal is a need of extra calories
five-person dextrose can be given some q
IP for rats we recommend in general
depends on their size to adult rats are
between five and ten MLS pre-op or even
during surgery is hey Michaela thank you
for the note it is always a pleasure to
see you listening to you and hope that
you can make any name well it happens to
be that I'll be grown there the Chilean
mayor to work with you folks and look
forward to that too Micaela hey what do
you think about fasting prior to surgery
to rodents I don't think it needs to be
done because of their high metabolic
rate they are very few exceptions in
which a pheasant may be necessary and
and and the fact that they don't have
the ability to vomit like a dog or a cat
can it makes it unnecessary to faster it
Louis Catalina from Chile hello Catalina
how are you I would like to she wrote in
spanish and go to translate would like
to know a how to work the pole stop
protocol in animals and then Oh in a
tooth research well data here's we're
not sure exactly what all you're asking
what they're the tooth researcher deals
with but should consider the issue of
dextrose for example can give extra
calories
and in some cases and I you know there
are some papers written in which they're
a hyper alimentation feeling through a
natural amount at the base it depends on
the invasiveness of the tooth research
is and it can be given to some gastric
Canyon left but I sorry I don't know
exactly what it is that you're doing but
maybe we can discuss that offline you
can also send me an email a day are
there any of them non-pharmacological
methods to minimize variables themselves
well we discuss a few today and again a
good enriched environment by a serve of
the company provides very good can
provide good input here and yeah they're
also there are other methods that needs
to be implemented of course I could not
cover all of them and for when it when
individuals enter the animal room the
line sneak perhaps likes me to be
attenuated that will help post off a
loud voices cell phones should not be
used in the animal rooms and you should
be away from high noises perhaps you can
place their Broughton racks and the back
of the room to minimize his friends so
they can be more isolated so there are
all kinds of things you could do a good
morning is it worth to use as quetta
means i'm not sure what s ketamine
instead of normal art ketamine I'm sorry
I don't know what s ketamine or r
ketamine is and one of the benefits I
apologize but I don't know if you want
to send a question again and specify
what our convenience versus can amino be
glad to read it again how many days
post-op the Year twice to increase the
calories again we are it depends on the
surgical procedure and if you're gonna
have a highly invasive procedure then
you might want to consider more day so
there's not an answer specific answer
and I'll tell you that I do at least the
first day
right now believes and Athleta to that
the first six hours and then with
recovery of animals on rodents in
particular is a most crucial time so I
encourage you to consider at least doing
something at first I was the first day
do you thank you for the presentation go
to think again I could you please repeat
or provide that webpage you just
mentioned a I will it let me let me tell
you i don't know if i could email your
the need look it out very quickly and
now we'll fix biles serve a bio serve
gosh i apologize i think is a be i 0 s
ii RV hyphen no be I Oh hyphen s ii RV
com I believe I'm not sure exactly feel
free to contact me offline what I did is
that all I don't know how to bring my
first light with my email and I could
email it to you thank you so so much you
learn a lot in your presentation where
I'm glad you did okay to clarify s
ketamine or are k I mean I ketamine and
then shoot and then shomers I'm sorry I
just really not familiar data oh there
you go somebody sent me the bio serve
thank yourself on for setting that is
bio is be I Oh hyphen s ii RV calm again
be AI o hyphen s ii RV com let me see if
I have any more questions good morning
and gaining in Spanish and I'll how to
translate here do you consider to inject
the glucose post-op in many cases
it will help a so five percent dextrose
it could really help bring some
necessary calories it will be a clinical
assessment you see the animals are not
eating well and then they need a little
extra calories that could help yes good
idea oh by the way and a bio serve is
also one of the exhibitors at the
conference so thank you Mary for
reminding me of that you want to visit
that the buyer serve the conference okay
I think those are all the questions
thank you for your questions thank you
for your attendance it's been a pleasure
and feel free to contact me and I I
think I don't know how to bring my first
line i'm gonna try to bring it if you
want my my email if you wanna send me a
more questions in the future i'm trying
to bring i don't know how to get to the
beginning so i'm kind of drunk driving
you crazy here but here's my contact
information again feel free to contact
me anytime okay so this concludes this
presentation I'm going to leave this
light for a couple more minutes just in
case anybody wants to write down but
information thank you it's been a
pleasure oh it seems to be another
question okay here that came up are the
bacon softies or Die chiapas consider
variables I could however I think that
the variable of pain post-op could be
more severe than the variable they can
introduce where the bacon softest or the
gels so we need to balance that thank
you very much for the knowledge
greetings from Chile well Catalina thank
you very much well I will say the next
thing that's the concept but thank you
for the compliment and I let me see
there any other questions thank you so
much this was a wonderful presentation
thank you bears to read these things but
thank you so much and I it's been a
pleasure and i hope i can interact with
some of you guys again don't hesitate to
contact me I think it's the pond for
including me in there
the rebar sensitivity the bar conference
life this is a great group of people and
and as see other places but I think at
this point I'm going to stop the
presentation and sorry I cannot answer
anymore I wish I could but greetings to
all die